it can only be downhill from here
the uh um
the concept of a competitive equilibrium
as well as one i'm at the taking for
granted that you have some idea what
we're talking about here
i'll go over some elements that
are relevant to this particular story
this is a particular approach
to the question of finding competitive
governments an attempt
in a to be
a description of how the market
finds the international we have a theory
that
in some sense or another and i mean let
me discuss realism
i mean i got involved with questions of
realism here
you all know the problems uh that
um the economy in some broad sense
is described by a set of equilibrium
relationships
i said the governing
principle of a capitalist economy is the
use of the price system
that individuals respond
to prices but the prices themselves have
to be such
that the economy in some sense or
another is in balance
and particularly we talk about the ideas
of supply and demand
and i don't think i have to describe in
any in detail what i mean by that but
that people offer goods for sale others
buy them
but this somehow there shouldn't be
there shouldn't be a discrepancy and in
the end what's bought
is what's what's offered is sold people
don't
offer things that aren't going to be
sold and
prices play a role in regulating that
it's an attempt
this is a particular attempt to carry
out the vision and it's mostly
derived from they developed approach
which
developed in 19th century uh by mostly
by
leon balras the french economist
um followed up there others involved and
i may mention them
and was kind of formalized
really not you know in a way in the the
20th century mostly about paul samuelson
and then the question is does it really
work can we
derive the urge can we derive results
for that
and the answer is yes and no
um other there are other approaches um
which we you'll now talk about and i was
uh
professor rough gardeners give me a talk
and i know she he'll go and do
a project but the point about the method
the approach that's talking about here
the word i'll have to use the french
word taton
it's because it's it is barred into
english and everybody uses it
uh it's a word that was coined by uh uh
or applied to this
process by the varus but it's somehow
it has in its french form it's become
the standard word
i'll have to use it the
uh the the virtue is it permits
a decentralized approach there are
methods of computing equilibria
which are not decentralized they require
central information
i'll i'll allude to this i'll
come over this again and um
therefore they can't be descriptive they
may be they may
be appropriate for a planned economy but
they're not descriptive
of a private enterprise economy this
is probably very badly descriptive
anyway but at least
it it satisfies the informational
requirements
uh that are consistent people don't have
to know more than they
reasonably expected to know
um i'm gonna have four headings and
first i'm gonna go into the uh
element the relevant elementary concepts
of demand supply
and equilibrium but you are familiar
with you but i want to recall them for
our purpose
and then two is the description what the
process is
and i'll show sufficient conditions that
it works in in some cases there are two
deleting cases and then i'll
uh remark briefly wrap up the end there
that's less important
let me i'll say something about the
history the
prehistory perhaps of this let's say
before vulras
it all depends there are various ways of
formulating the economy
um and various assumptions we can make
and it turns out that
under some very
extreme conditions the
prices can be determined solely by
supply factors
by cost factors the probably
the technology technology this is
basically that this idea there's only
one
basic primary resource now the let me
say in the vision of the economy
that was which is the standard vision
economy
we start off with there are some things
we just have
from the primary factors that's the way
that's usually used
land um
the labor
although there's a problem with labor
but minerals things that are available
and that are given to the economy
and the presumably the process is that
somehow they're used
by firms and transformed into other
products
and they're eventually bought by
consumers
where the consumers get their income
well they hold some of these primary
factors
like labor and or maybe other things
and sell them to the firms
this gives them the income also the
firms may make profits in which
the and some of the consumers own parts
of those firms
so this gives you the income necessary
to buy the
products um that's the division of the
economy
if you assume there is actually only one
primary factor
and then it really turns out that prices
can be determined by the forces of
competition oh yeah i'm sorry one more
remark
that's obvious each individual is
supposed to it's kind of small
on the economy and therefore it takes
the prices
as given it's the competitive hypothesis
and we're talking here about competitive
equilibrium
uh the monopolies bring in new
and and still more difficult questions
of adjustment uh the um
and that's all i'm going to maintain
this because i'm giving history not
trying to
defend the assumptions uh the um
so the the idea that there's only one
primary factor
then in effect all production consists
of using that factor
and therefore the prices are
proportional
to the amount of the f is used directly
or indirectly as i may buy
i may be affirmative buy something from
another firm but directly or indirect
native prices
and this is one of the reasons why the
questions of price adjustment
don't play much of a role in the period
let's say from adam smith
which may think it was the founding of
modern economics
of course they're always predecessors
but
you know let's let's just leave the
conventional account there
um when he discusses value it's really
how much of the primary factor that's
used these they were not so clear to
ricardo is
clearer on this on these points and
um you may say where does labor come
into this
well there really was an idea that labor
is produced by goods that's to say
if you have too many workers they starve
the population is too big they start to
death that's malthus
but it was taken up by all the other
economists
um so in some sense labor is a produced
good
the amount of labor produ given by the
supply by a single individual is taken
as given you weren't thinking of
negotiating hours of work and of course
one of the troubles is the 19th century
war on
it was perfectly clear that wages were
well above
any kind of subsistence level
people were not uh the the the size of
the
labor force was not determined by wages
they're not literally just barely enough
see the idea of multiples was that more
if
more people came on they'd starve and if
there were less people
wages would rise and that would induce a
population increase
so the equilibrium was that people would
just barely
had a wage just barely enough to keep
them alive well that
that's the 19th century war on that
clearly was false
and and the idea that labor must be an
independent source so already
more than one primary factor which case
it was not going to be very easy to have
a price this is one of the reasons
why people paid relatively little
attention to demand functions
to the question demand because the
prices were being determined on the
supply side
and by the time of all ross this was no
longer a supportable thing and there are
various other stages in the uh for
example in the discussion of foreign
trade
um john stuart mill pointed out you have
to figure what's the demand
by germany for english products what's
the demand by england
for german products so you already have
that demand and this deep
so this would affect the exchange rate
or the exchange rate would
affect this but in turn equilibrium
would require the exchange rate be set
at the right
uh level so the trade was balanced so
there were
all sorts of reasons why in the late
19th century
the importance of demand as a
determinant of crisis became
more central and it wasn't only valor
stanley evans uh
karl menger were developing the same
ideas this summer
time i just give this historical
background to explain why the interest
in this thing
um now this is sketching the uh
the the uh what is the theory of the
frame of the
this is all very familiar you suppose
you imagine the set of prices given
the firm chooses an output vector but of
course has to be technologically
possible
and that's what is well the production
relation there's some kind of
relationship
the input the inputs and outputs
have to be you might have more than one
out this permits more than one output a
firm may produce several goods
a firm need uses goods in the production
including labor of course and
and other things and there's got to be
some relation between them
so it's got to be a constraint there's
given the inputs and all the outputs put
one you know
the the other the output the last one is
determined
but it's a constraint to the the prices
don't enter into it
the firm maximizes profits standards
have taken the prices given so it winds
up
with a vector the
vector for the firm f is designated by
yf
where the positive um positive means an
output negative means an input
components of yf um
that gives you the supply and demand
function
um so many households
start with some supplies of some of
these goods these primary factors
like labor um also they may only share
the profits of each firm
i'm not going to write out the formulas
here that are
trivial so it can shoot
now then it has a budget constraint
namely
that it's expenditures p times xh
that to those expenditures um equals the
value of the primary factors it owns
which it sells plus their share
of the firm profits and so that
determined
then it chooses i didn't say you know
we assume it maximizes utility
i haven't spelled out but there is some
deterministic process
by which the given the prices and given
the budget constraint
the firm choose the i'm sorry the
household
chooses its uh um
demand these are typically non-native
okay um
so this gives rise to the concept of
what the excess demand is
the demand minus the supply
and you see for
is the supply the
demand is the sum for the private
householders
of xh now when i say demand remember
there are inter-industry demands also
but they're assumed under the y vector
the demand by the y vector the demand is
represented by a negative element
it's a uh an output isn't that
a positive element so the excess demand
the
amount which demand exceeds supply which
could be negative of course
is given by this formula is that clear
any question about that
now from this just for this elementary
presentation
valrass noticed suppose you add up all
these budget constraints
you have the sum of the xhs
you have on this side there's this side
you have the sum of the x stars
and you have the total of the firm
profits
the firm profits are p times yf
um so
if you have that all up see it's p so if
you take p
the vector p the inner product of p and
z of z
you have the value of demand which is
now
so there's x star h which cancels px
storage
and here you have the sum of the profits
which adds up to the total
amount of profits distributed to the
households since the household so the
owner
the stockholders who are the are the
owners of this
so we have a very simple relationship
that's the definition
of p times e of p is zero we call that
today is generally known as valrassa's
law
so this is one this is a very elementary
derivation obviously
what i'm getting at here the direction
i'm going is what
conditions do we impose on z because z
is going to play a role
in our dynamics
and turns out
that i'm giving some very elementary
derivations in fact there are only
two properties um
they can say now are we overlooked after
what i'm saying
their firms are maximizing right doesn't
this give
constraints well there's a
general results uh uh usually referred
to as the
the the mantel theorem that
uh no the you could you can get almost
any
aggregate excess demand
even though you're assuming each
individual is a maximizing utility
the maximization of utility
does not impose the the mere fact that
you're maximizing if you knew the
utility functions
of course you'd have a constraint you'd
be you'd use econometrics really
but if you don't if you're just trying
to say what can you deduce merely from
the fact that you're maximizing utility
it turns out that individuals are
maximizing utility it turns out that
in the aggregate this is essentially no
constraint at all
any function satisfying
balrog's law and homogeneity and
continuity
i didn't i didn't spell out continuity
but that's
um that is possible
so in this argument okay this is the
second
the second constraint is suppose all
prices are multiplied
by a constant same constant
um well
the firm obviously the firm's
maximization is unaffected by that
it's only the test just multiplies the
profits
and similarly the budget constraint
is essentially the same so multiplying
all the prices by a constant is
uh uh leaves all the behavior it leaves
the excess demand on change
or another way of saying it is
homogeneous the excess demand function
is homogeneous of degree zero in
crisis so these are the two basic
properties that we can deduce from this
model
there's not much else
what do you mean by equilibrium well a
simplest way of putting it the way val
ross would have put it is simply
excess demand to zero that means demand
is equal to supply in every
market there's the idea the coordinating
function of the market
is expressed through market clearing
now that's the way you put it the modern
way
uh which is um
it's already hinted at in if you look at
the um
creators the founders of the so-called
neoclassical point of view valrass
menger or
kevin's there's a hint especially with
bankers
this is more than anybody else that some
goods could really be free
suppose you take a good let the price go
to zero
people may not buy an infinite amount of
it
you breathe air air is a free good
it's there's a lot more air that we need
to breathe
it's not scarce so even though we pay
nothing for it
there's no no there's no particular
problem so there's if you have a
negative excess demand
when the price is zero then
uh we can call that equilibrium and i
mentioned that
uh although we're not going to pay much
attention to it
this would be a more modern point of
view
now one question especially if you use
this model this
was probably brought out most explicitly
by
a person who later became much more
famous as a status mathematical
statistician abraham walt
he was still graduate student at the
university of vienna
um he was essentially
you know came from romania was my
teacher
i came from one of my teachers and they
came from
uh for a student from romania um
and uh they needed money so
there was a banker who had had
background schlesinger who had
background in
that actually got a phd in economics
before he go ahead
when it went to the family business and
got kind of curious about the existence
of equilibrium some
some germans had written some articles
pointing out it's not quite as self
not quite as simple as it sounds and um
he had an idea which was this
essentially this
corner idea that the the free goods idea
and but he didn't have any math so he
he was uh put in contact with
all this unemployed student who then
needed money
who then wrote some paper pointing out
the existence pointing out that
the how the with this free good problem
you could prove the assumptions you made
were
so strong as not to be regarded as
useful today but it's the first paper
which gave a real uh proof
of existence weekly under some
conditions the conditions were
were too strong to be proud to be
reasonable but
um and mckenzie and
brunei first really gave the proofs that
was after
nash published it was nash's techniques
that told us what to do i got to say
that as soon as i saw that
scratched my head and said this sounds
like if you reinterpret it
it could be made in the competitive
globe there were some tricks to it but
it was not
basically that was the idea um now
okay so now valaross was trying to
formulate the idea of how do you
how does the market in some sense get
into equilibrium
how the what is it that surprised me
because people have to proceed on the
basis
and there is a an idea which would
probably vaguely
what most people would vaguely have used
even well before varus that somehow
supply exceeds demand then prices are
going to
the price on that market is going to if
you take a particular market
some good one good the price will go
down
if there's more supply than demand and
you know he was partly he was influenced
by descriptions of how the stock market
came into equine we know that uh if the
how the stock market is somehow prices
is announced and
then it turns out that there's more
there's more available than people are
uh
are buying so somebody else that offers
at a lower price
and so forth and so on um
so intuitively and if you take any one
market it's a kind of a very reasonable
kind of assumption
um and you find vague statements
uh about of this kind and almost all the
economists
but it was varus who made it explicit
um now what it but then the question
what do you mean by it well he actually
when he he has rather words which
supply give the idea that i just said
but when he actually tries to explain it
in some detail
he does something different and it's
what's
usually called the gauss-seidel method
of solving
the system of equations start with an
arbitrary guess then you can
look at the if reply to markets look at
the markets
one at a time you take the first market
you have
just a guess of the prices and so the
market is not it may not be an
equilibrium
access demand repository what you do is
change the price of that good
say good one until that market clears
given the other prices see the
contribution of valeros is that the
demand
for commodity depends on the prices of
other commodities
that's the key that was the key thing
which
would they seem so elementary
and in fact almost necessary but it was
not really stated explicitly to these
the the this trio independently
the valros jefferson manger stated
um the um so you
this idea was you take the first good
you leaving all the
prices of the goods true to end
unchanged
change the price the first good until
the market for good one clears
okay now let's go to market two with the
new price for commodity one
change the price of commodity two
until it clears and
keep on doing it then when you're
through of course the market
the last market will clear but by this
time this may have upset
these changes may have upset the
clearing of the previous markets so now
you start the process over again
now that's not a process which always
converges there's no particular
yeah he had a vague statement that the
which will
formalize later that the price of
commodity uh
that that the most important factor in
the demand for good
is the its price the other prices matter
but its price is the most important
thing and somehow therefore
but it was just hand waving there's no
proof of any kind
and furthermore the word verbal language
is really different
um and
it's what i said before on each market
separately let the price
rise and fall according to excess demand
rise if this excess demand is positive
fall for six of them
well if it was not really to do paul
samus and this is
this is 70 years later formalized that
thing
that approach which as i say is really
in the language that val ross uses but
not
when he gets gets formal and it's that
simplest form that the price the price
of
on market i is proportional
to the excess demand
which means it rises with access to man
this is a linear you could try
non-linear
approaches but let's forget about that
um
if zi is zero then you don't change the
price
but of course the price on some other
market may be changing and that will
upset the price on this market
the the you need those constants there
because
this the relation depends on the units
in which you measure the commodities
and if you change the units you so you
have to have some kind of a constant
there which depends
on the units and
he used the word tatum that's which i
say is stuck in english
the a by the way should have a
circumflex over it but i was
i could can't quite figure out how to
put circumflexes on so
i didn't bother it's uh and the word
in french means it's a word means
something like groping
or a prior you might say approximation
um but you see now it specializes
because the price on one market
depends only on the excess demand on
that market which is a decentralized
form it is something which is observable
everybody knows access to man i mean
just a man that's obtained by
people put in their bids their requests
and thanks
now um
it turns out one thing we immediately
was what a result you immediately get
you take this and differentiate it
with respect to time and then use
equation t and then
take account of w which is remember that
p
times z is zero
um then this is constant
so at least one thing we know when i
it's not
that's not a great property but it's at
least the means the thing doesn't go
wildly
it's a bounded path
all right now a lot of effort was paid
into whether this mom works
and a lot of the a lot there's a whole
literature i'm not going to discuss
which looks just at local stability
supposing you take the equilibrium which
remember is defined by
that z is zero that the prices which
make z
zero um he asked
is that a locally stable so there's a
whole literature on this
which i've contributed to and uh started
long before about hicks and
a whole long list of people did some
very good work
some um i'm not going to local stability
i
want to discuss global today um
but this led uh landed her with
myself to be thinking about what is what
what assumptions
would guarantee local stability
and then we found a result
and then into talking to a mathematician
henry block he said well but it's
globally
your method's globally stable which was
a surprise
uh kind of a surprise
there's a special case supposing
let me it's called gross substitutes the
reason is there is a term
net substitutes which means something
different it's the slutsky
for the economist it's the slotsky
relation
um but i'm not on friday i'll just
explain why the word gross
um frozen one price rises
now you might expect the demand to fall
although that's not necessarily true by
the way
economic theory points out there are
cases
so-called giffen goods where the rise in
price will increase the demand
um but the normal situation
that means that you're going to divert
person power to other things so
it seems that not unreasonable no it's
not
it's it can't be derived from economic
theory because there are these known
exceptions
um that the probably that the demand for
other goods
so the price one price rise the demand
for other goods
will rise people will substitute away
and that's called growth substitutions
we demand
say that if any price rises the demand
for
all other goods will be will rise
um so look at the
i don't think read this is the partial
of say x
xj was supposed to be the partial xj
with respect to pi
um now as you take this is in other
words
the jacobian of the function of the
vector function
c z of p so take the the matrix of uh
uh of the the partial derivatives
uh so we're assuming the off diagonal
elements of j are positive
we call that assumption gs well it turns
out that if gs holds
the tatomon process converges the
equilibrium is unique in this case
and the uh i didn't mention but there
might be more than one equilibrium
um the equilibrium is unique in the
under these assumptions
and the convergence the amount i forgot
to write down the method
which is the op enough uh
function you know and what you take is
take
the largest ratio of the actual price to
the equilibrium price
i should have ripped it up i forgot
about it um
take the i take any point take the price
take the largest
the the commodity with the largest ratio
of p i to p star i
you can easily show in the gross up so
that that must be decreasing
and of course it's zero at the when you
get when you're in equilibrium that's
zero
so that's the the the laptop method
um there's a second case
called the dominant diagonal
now um
for this i'm not going to use the tattoo
ma process and
as i wrote it but a slightly a slight
variation of it
namely this is the you take one
commodity
and consider it as a numeraire that's
another french word which
from valeros which has passed into
english usage
in other words we're going to say that
we're going to hold the price of the nth
good
let's call it the nth good constant
now in order for that to be satisfactory
you got to make sure that
at equilibrium the price is not going to
be zero
so you've got to assume that that when
the price of that commodity approaches
zero the excess demand goes to infinity
um so that but we apply the tatamin to
all the other goods
um so let j prime be the jacobian of
excess demand functions considering only
the non-numerator goods you just delete
the nth row and column
now supposing that you have some fixed
weights
um so the j prime has a dominant
diagonal those ways put another way
if we can choose the units for the
commodities
so that j prime
has a dominant diagonal for all possible
prices
that means an effect that the price of
that good
is more important
in determining the the excess demand and
the prices of all the other goods
variations of the exact variations in
the prices
of the price for each commodity other
than the numerator
the demand the excess demand
is more sensitive to the price of that
than to the prices of all the other
goods put together
that's what it comes down to then again
um and i've forgotten italy i've had a
function here
i should have looked it up you can prove
that you have global stability and these
are the two main cases
now they're they're not entirely
trivial but um uh they're
um uh they're not um
they're certainly not exhaustive and you
see the biggest problem
is what are called complementarities
supposed to take bread and butter that's
a classic example
if the price of butter goes up the
demand for bread may fall
you want your you want bread you want
butter with your bread if the broth is
expensive you may decide not
to buy the bread so even though you see
the gross substitute would say the price
of butter goes up
you stop eating butter but then you buy
more bread but that may not be the case
so complementarities are one of the main
problems
in in this and
i was there were counter examples i've
finally i was going to present them but
i decided they're kind of fiddly
um you know everybody says you have to
do some very detailed calculations
um to make them come out but but they're
pretty simple
um that was first done by herbert scarf
and then
a somewhat simpler one by david gale
showed that the tatami mall does not
always converge
now remember the assumptions we have are
pretty weak all we have is
balrassa's law and homogeneity really
so it's not totally surprising that even
though those do have
surprisingly strong assumptions you're
not going to get everything
um and as i say once
once it was later shown by a number of
authors
that as i mentioned before
that um the economic theory doesn't put
much of a constraint on the aggregate
demand fund on the cons on the
production side there are big
constraints
but the household side does not
aggregate
unless you make some very strong
assumptions
and this is the this is the reason why
you can get sort of
almost any behavior you want on the
consumer side
if your prescriber can demand functions
on the consumer side and you can
and uh you can get but you get anything
any results you want so it's not
surprising that simple advice
now i'm pretty coming to the end coming
to the end of this uh the um
this
as i said in fact the examples in order
to show it consists of saying that firm
that the both of the examples depend on
the i use the following trick
they find an economy with a unique
equilibrium
they take pure exchange economies
there's no production all you've got
is a bunch of goods and the consumers
are redistributing them
among themselves um that you find
there's
they set up an economy with a unique
equilibrium
but that that equilibrium is locally
unstable
well obviously it can't it can't be
globally stable then
um and that's uh so it turns out to be
elementary but somewhat
have to do sorry like a fair amount of
arithmetic or elementary algebra
um now if you're trying to find the
equilibrium
this suggests alternative approaches
um and they essentially shows that
knowing the excess demand function alone
is not enough you need more information
and the information consists in the
jacobian
it's going to they're not only the the
excess demands but they're derivatives
um now for example that uh
a very simple observation um
that supposing the jacobian never
vanishes
um then it's quite clear that a quasi
it's really elementary to prove that a
quasi-newton
uh method you know what i mean by
quasi-newton methods that
i know it's you know what you mean by
newton's method
well supposing you used as a
differential equation rather than
a difference equation there's you move
you just move
small steps in the direction given by
the newton method so
which of course uses the derivatives
these are the uh the jacobian
um then that it's
very elementary to show that that method
converges
and smale did the hard job of supposing
the jacobian does vanish
and then each time you move and hit a
point where the jacobian is zero you
have to
do something complicated uh that the
method will work
anyway um whether it's a practice i'm
not sure that anybody uses it
professor roughgarden will know much
better than i whether
anybody uh uses methods like that as a
product
in fact so
there's a whole literature as you know
and you'll be hearing much more about it
which i'm not acquainted with very well
about
the use of of thinking of the process
i'd say
the proof of the existence is not your
fixed point argument like
as in uh nash essentially using
a generalized uh fixed point of the
so-called kakatani or phenomenon
fixed-point theorem two different
theorems but they're
trivial equivalent and um
so then the question just becomes how do
you find a fixed point
um and there are
i guess there's some questions whether
you that problem is solved
it can be approximately solved although
the word approximation is a little
delicate
okay and we'll hear much more about it
okay thank you
patience
i'll be glad to answer questions and
through my race
questions
thank you for your talk uh could you
perhaps say something about the
potential role of government
in either stabilizing things or steering
things to a better equilibrium
um there
well okay there are
that's a big problem that's a big
problem many answers to it
one problem okay
first place there's a question does the
market work
and this is this is an old thing bob
ross already talked about it and i think
maybe even before that
oh yes sorry before that um that there
are things which the market doesn't take
care of
air pollution is the obvious that is the
classic example has always been it's
been used for the last hundred
uh 100 years uh in
about thirteen hundred okay
the then king of england issued an edict
that coal should not be burned in the
city of london
it was not enforced as you can imagine
if anybody reads sherlock holmes stories
as i do
we'll do know the reference to these
peace soup vlogs
where a person walks 10 steps and
disappears
those are the result of smoke due to
from coal
and um and people were dying as well
more seriously
um the uh so in other words there are
externalities so there are also things
so let me
take that as given um there are things
where you need
very large scale and to leave it in
private hands
a dam supplying irrigation water
believe in private hands would be that
we create monopolies well in fact we
have it with electricity
where of course to the size we have
nobody so then you have state regulation
okay those those are the classic
examples
um you really there's
harvard uh there's a there's a deeper
problem
we said that markets are not complete
don't cover everything
in a different sense and that's about
the future
or about uncertainty
risks whenever i go i go into
i started a new business with a new
product
well i don't know how much it's going to
cost
really you know having that experience
and actually doing this on a
scale so i don't know my costs i don't
know if there's a market first
in an ideal in the world that extending
the valrazian story
would be that you have markets for the
risks
but clearly you can't have a market for
that risk was the if the fellow's
insured
he's not going to bother doing anything
he's not going to bother doing anything
right he's just what's called moral
hazard
um so there are intrinsic cases where
the markets
fail and the fact the whole question of
the future
um i haven't discussed time here
i'm just trying time here is only
adjustment time
but supposing there's real time that's
to say i'm building i'm building
i'm putting an input today but the
output doesn't come till tomorrow
or 10 years from now um
well what if if i follow the market
solution i should have a market
which says five years from now i'm going
to you know i'm gonna
uh i'm selling now to somebody
somebody's buying from me
the delivery of a good five years from
now but we don't find it and
we can give a good story as to why we
don't find it
so markets are incomplete
and therefore in that sense government
guarantees
government regulation which says
they'll be around
can matter now of course as everybody
as easy to point out government
intervention
may not may create its own incentive
problems
so there's a delicate balancing that we
can go on and on
and of course i'm not even discussing
the question of instabilities arising in
the financial system
we should which i could go on for quite
a while
i don't want to take the time now it's a
good day too
great
you